spent some time talking about the new
version tonight and and some of the
features you know the i did that
training the other day and
yeah i just realized it wasn't enough
time to really cover everything that
you know
i i would like to cover um you know
because there's there's a lot of new
features
or you know some changes uh
to the software that
really makes it you know in my opinion
um
understanding what's happening in the
market a bit better and you know forget
about you know what's you know the
volatility of the markets you know i i
know i see a lot of people oh you know
it's impossible to trade these markets
because you know
it's down a half a percent you know one
and a half percent then it goes up
positive on the day then it goes back
down well
you know that's where watching the order
flow is going to come in handy and i'm
going to spend some time talking about
um
you know some of the the newer settings
so
for now
um
what i'll talk about first is i'll talk
about the value areas right because this
is something that i've been
wanting in there for
quite a while
and
it's just been hard to do you know
efficiently i mean i could put it in but
it would have made it slower um until my
programmer you know really
dove in deep with um ninjatrader and
figured out you know the way to do it
efficiently because
value areas right are areas that you're
always looking for the market to come
back to and
you know sort of in the past you know i
sort of a crude way of
me doing it was
you know i would i'd use these
volume profile tools like this that you
know like over a five minute period or i
even have tools you know where you can
draw from
you know any period you know you've seen
those those things where you could draw
a volume profile out
over a certain period
and
what i really wanted was something that
i could draw out
sort of like the virgin point of control
or virgin value areas you know areas
that aren't tested in the next bar
because oftentimes you know the value
overlaps right from one bar
to the next okay just goes
you know you can see you know since we
put the value areas on here right you
see where the value area is in a bar
and
generally they overlap you know by at
least a tick you know sometimes they're
inside the previous bar
and obviously sometimes you know like
this there
the next bar overlaps it by four ticks
or something
and
these are areas when you have that one
sort of left off
that you know are are great areas where
you're looking for the market to come
back and test it so this is just you
know the e-mini one-minute chart um you
know just you know go back to
you know the cash
open
uh where's cash open you know 8 30. and
like you see right often times they're
they're overlapping right they're
overlapping now
you know
just sort of down the line you know
maybe in a separate thing i'll do
you know one of the things that i like
to do
i don't have it on this pc yet
because i'm working with a programmer on
because he's got a tool for drawing out
you know it's one of those
volume profile tools right
and i like to take it from like swing
highs to swing lows and you know you see
where the value areas come out to but
that's somewhere down the line but for
now
you know dealing with these areas where
the value areas are
coming in to be retested right like i
said every bar it tends to be retested
right retest it here this one's retested
this one re-test the previous one this
one doesn't right it doesn't the next
bar
the value area is higher right so we
know that the market is
we can see the value area is obviously
moving higher right the value area high
is higher here
higher in this bar higher in this bar
higher in this bar okay so we already
know the market is starting to trend up
obviously point of controls are going up
delta's going up you got a little delta
surge going on right here
and of course
point of control is going higher
now we are
up here right
and we don't come back in and test this
point of control so we have that area in
here you know this area between 43 36
43 33
okay and then the next bar so
we got one bar where
we haven't come back into
the previous value area okay now we got
another bar
where it hasn't come into the previous
value area
and it's starting to trend higher okay
so i know already trending higher right
when i have two
of these virgin value areas so to speak
that's a good sign i know the market is
moving higher right because oftentimes
you're going to have a gap in the value
areas right and when i have a gap in the
value
right from this bar to this bar right
the value area high here to the value
area low here
this is a gap okay you see another gap
here but when i start seeing the gaps
like this i know the market's got a full
head of steam so the market is going up
right so i know i got this zone drawn
out this zone drawn out
when i have two in a row like that it's
generally
pretty clear which way you should be on
the market right you shouldn't be
looking for an area to get short
because i know i've got an area here
that could act as support i have an area
here that could act as support right so
we trade higher we hit the new high of
the day up here
56 was that 56 and a half
okay we start coming down all right so
where's my target going to be it's going
to be this first area in here
start coming off i got again value areas
are generally
retraced into in the next bar right
all these little value areas here get
retraced in in this big bar here and
then we got a new value area up here but
the next bar is trading within that
value still and the next buyer is still
trading within that value
market starts trading down we got this
big exposed value area right here
okay next bar it's below it
okay that's a good sign we got a gap
here in the value area
where to come back in x xbar
overlaps the previous bar right but
still hasn't traded back in there
this third bar it trades back in there
finally right trades in there by one
tick
right and then it comes off
lower lower lower to where right into
this previous value area
market rallies up a little bit
you know from this 38 area all the way
up to
the mid-40s
comes off
gets through this value area that's
already been
tested
trades down to where
the previous value area
right and then it bounces back up
okay and it comes off now
here's a
i didn't have a chance to talk about
this
over the weekend um
but this is a
bearish
area right it's it's in the red bar in a
sense that's why it's kicking it off red
if the bar is green
the value area zone will be green color
if the bar is red
and this is a red candle it will draw a
red zone out right that's why you have
red red red this one is a green okay so
but what's happening in this bar right
well the bar traded down
reversed up but still
closed red you know just by the sort of
the smallest amount the smallest margin
by about
three ticks
you know even though you know this is
one of those bullish candles you know
the candlestick guys
you know the hammer pattern right and
and i do
if this bar had turned green you know
this would be a nice bullish bar but
it's still red but you're still drawing
out that it's still drawing out that
zone
and
oftentimes you know people see
things on their chart red or green and
they think
you know traffic lights you know red
light
you do one thing green light you do
another thing and
you know this is where
using your brain has got to come in
handy you know okay you have a
small red candle okay even though it's a
reversal candle right
bone control is near the bottom
which is
you know if the scandal is green that'd
be a nice probably a prominent point of
control
and then
you just have this and people think well
you know i should be getting short right
well if you just like you would for an
imbalance right stacked imbalance if you
have that red zone drawn out and you're
trading above it it's invalidated
okay maybe in the next version
um
they'll maybe i could ask the programmer
put a feature in there to
undraw it's right because you're trading
above it but that's not really what you
want to do you should be able to
recognize that just by seeing well it's
you know
we're trading above the
resistance area right so it's
invalidated in that sense i'm not
necessarily looking for it to come back
down
and test it here
all right
then we got the little green candle
the next one here you know with the
little zone it goes a little bit higher
then it starts coming back down it's a
little tight in this area in here
right but i'm not looking at this
necessarily as being support i mean you
can but
that's not you know i'm not one of those
in that sense where it was
bearish now i'm looking for it to be
bullish you know i would just treat it
as as invalidated
um
market went up right you just traded
straight through these
previous zones okay um you know they're
not all going to work perfectly just
like did here
here and here
and
you get up here you know people say well
why is this one drawn out as gray that's
because the candle is a doji candle open
and closed at the same price
so it's not going to draw it red or it's
not going to draw it green okay i mean
you had this small green one in here
right where it came out just
the next bar was above it and this green
gray bar this doji candle traded into it
then it rallied up to that new high
there
okay now right now i'm just covering the
value area ones
because that's all i have set on this
chart and
it gets down in here again
this candle is kind of similar to this
red candle earlier
obviously the only difference is this is
a red candle this is a green candle any
point of control is towards the bottom
but this candle is green you know the
whole value area is below the previous
bar's value area just like here
again you know
some people might be willing to take
this as support i i just i wouldn't
right it's just i'm not wired that way
if it's a green candle yeah i would take
it as support as it came down in here
again it traded in here
traded in that area
you know bounced up a little bit wasn't
a big move
you know honestly this type of market
it's
they don't look like big moves you know
but you're not gonna move you know just
you know the high is what 32 and a
quarter
you know up to what seven
thirty seven so you know it's almost a
five point move even though it doesn't
look like much
then you start trading down
again similar thing that you have here
on this bar right it's that red candle
point of control is towards the bottom
right the value area is below the
previous bars value but it's a red
candle so i'm not looking as this to be
support when i have a red candle and i
have the zone drawn out i'm looking for
it to be resistance right i expect the
next bar to be trading below it just as
i would for a stacked
selling imbalance
right there's you know there are times
where if i
stack selling and balance here let's
take a quick look
so for example
um
okay like here right this is stack
buying and balance right i don't expect
the next bar to be below it right if i'm
taking a stacked buying and balance i
expect the next bar to be trading above
it like you have you know down here
here's a stack buying a balance right
the next bar should at least be above it
if the next bar is trading below it
like it was doing up here
you know that that signal is invalidated
right away
i'm not looking
to
do anything
on that type of bar
so here right so you have your zone
being drawn out
it goes two bars
and then the third bar trades right into
that zone
and that sells off right so now i got a
green candle right
got the green zone
even though the market sold off and came
back up it's a green bar right with the
green zone i'm expecting the market to
be above it right not below it
so
even though you have zones drawn out
right you still got to sort of put the
pieces together right if it's a green
zone and you're looking for the market
to come back
you're looking for it to come back from
above
not below you know even though in this
case it did come back up
to here
um
but again you know if you're selling it
in here
it still
kept coming back and and stopped you out
the best way to trade it is if it's a
red candle look for the market to start
moving down and then come back up and
test it if it's a green candle
right you're looking for the market to
go up then come back and test it
right like here right the red candle
right the red candle the red zone
markets sold off came back up
tested it
came back off again it doesn't look like
much right i mean if you're selling it
just right here at the top of the zone
at the bottom of the zone that's
what 23
and two bars later
you know it's trading 16.
that's
you know
that's why i can't add
um seven points right there um but again
you know five points is good enough to
get out of it what's your risk right
you're just
selling it right here at 23 you know
maybe a stop you know
23 24
24 it's on at 23 put a stop up there 25
two points
you know to get five six points that's
what two and a half three to one just
like here right even if you're just
putting the stop in right i'll show you
a short right in here at 20. yeah it
pulls back
up to what 22 and a half
and then just sort of go sideways
another little zone here now personally
i prefer to take these zones where
they're drawn out a couple of bars you
know if it's just one bar
it could be just the market starting to
go sideways personally i just find them
a little bit more effective when there's
space in between
but again you know
an issue when you're dealing with space
in between is if the market has a strong
sell-off and starts rallying it could
keep railing back up before it sells off
again like it did here right it rallied
um the bottom of this zone we're looking
at what 17 and a half rallies all the
way back up to the other side 19 and a
half gets all the way up to what 22
and three-quarters
before selling off right then you got
another zone right it's below it's below
that's what you want to see
right it's not just about well okay i
have a zone here being drawn
i'm going to wait for it to come back to
take the trade
you know you have that that spot okay
one way to trade it
is for that pullback
all right
another way is when you see things
happening in the order flow right when
the order flow is
uh we want to say conducive
when the order flow is in this case
bearish right then you're going to be
trading in that direction right you're
not
looking for a buy yet right if
you're under here right then you start
seeing the bullish things come in you
know the bullish prominent point of
control
okay
you know you're starting to see point
controls move higher you're getting long
even if you're getting long you know you
have this resistance here right for the
market to come back
get to that area
up around you know 17 18 in here okay
that's
unfortunately that's going to be
your resistance right you're
you're i don't say target but it's going
to come back up into that area and has a
chance to sort of just rotate around it
which it did i mean even though it
traded a little bit higher it more or
less sort of hung in that area and
traded
sideways
right now it comes back here
right now you've got that bearish zone
coming in let me expand this chart a
little bit here
okay so we have this zone and the next
bar again it's a red candle and again
you know this is the type of bar that
candlestick guys love right it's a
hammer
right you got point of control the
bottom half of the bar the whole value
area is at the bottom half the bar
problem this is still a red candle but
it trades up to the bottom of that value
area by you know it's one tick away what
do you have you have that exhaustion
print there the five
right okay doesn't even get back into
that zone next bar
just
same level right below it
by a tick
then you got the bearish slingshot
right so you know that you have this
area up in here
right you don't have to sit there and
wait you know for one
later in the day if it comes back to it
you know you have that area
and when you have an area like that the
market can and often does move away from
it right now it could just
have two bearish things and third bar
come right back into it okay
but you know you have a potential
for a move to happen
okay so it's not just
buying you know
trading the pullback buying the dip
you know you have that potential for
that move right and if you now you're
starting to see you have that big
bearish
signal going on right here
you got the exhaustion print when you
tried to come back into that area
you come again next bar you come back
into that area you've got the bearish
slingshot poc
and the market had a nice sell-off right
even if it's just you know you sold off
to here and it starts coming back you're
thinking
i'm gritting your teeth open oh my gosh
don't come back you know up higher
it gives you that
bearish prominent point control right
here
okay
you know i i can stay in the trade right
comes down
makes that new lower low from earlier
right there
right and it just keeps working its way
down
down down down even the
few bullish signals that you got right
bullish eva right here okay because we
got bullish eva here so you've gotten
along well the next bar
didn't go any higher neither did the
second bar after that right when
whenever you have like these bullish
signals like a bearish slingshot poc or
a bullish eva
you need the next bar
to have that follow-through order flow
right you need it to still keep going up
in that direction just as going down
on the bearish signal right preferably
in the next bar if not the next bar then
the bar after it i usually give it two
bars
once in a while you know if it market if
it's a slow market or if it's at night
evening session i'll give it three bars
because a lot of times at night session
well
except for the last week um
it's just
not much activity
now
so to get no bullish
follow-through order flow here
got no bullish follow-through order flow
here
okay so you know there's been a couple
times that you're expecting this market
to rally and it couldn't even muster
that rally i mean look at this bar here
nice strong positive delta plus 1200
but the next bar couldn't even go any
higher
right and it just stayed inside
inside the previous bar's value area
that's not bullish even though this bar
had nice bullish
delta even though this bar had nice
bullish
slingshot point of control
it didn't do anything it didn't go
higher and in the end all you ended up
with was this red bar but a red bar with
a
exhaustion print four
okay and then the markets keeps trading
down
i mean we came back to this
4296 area right we have the zone
if you could see it on your chart but
it's it's a zone from
way earlier
forgot what time it was
we rallied in the morning
um went all the way back
here
that's from four in the morning
okay
came all the way back
until
that's what 11
something
oops here
came back into there you know 96 this is
96 right here i mean it rallied up to o2
so
it rallied it wasn't you know didn't
bounce for the whole day and rally up to
new highs
it did bounce off that level and then
just sort of rotate around you know just
sort of went sideways sideways sideways
then you get down here now you have a
bullish eba that's why it's
blue color right the normal
value area if it's green
it'll be green a normal value area if
it's bullish if it's
a bullish eba excuse me
it'll be blue
now if it was a bearish
a bearish eba
you'd be a darker red because the normal
red if you were to go in and change the
colors
in the settings
just pull that up here
uh so if you were to scroll down
put it up here
right the evas are blue and red the
normal
value area
zone that's going to be drawn out is red
and green
if i were you if you want to keep it but
it's going to be a darker red if it's a
eva
because the opacity is set to 50 as
opposed to set to 20.
and again you know maybe you don't like
the color
scheme you can change it right so if you
don't want the
zones you know drawn out red and green
you can change it to whatever color you
know pink and yellow you know it's up to
you you could change those you could
adjust those colors
um
okay so you know it pulled back it got
within that area right up to the upper
level of this bullish eva
and you know again doesn't look like
much of a move
it's sad you know
s ps
it used to be such a nice calm contract
to trade
it doesn't look like much of a move but
it's it'll move from 95 all the way up
to it's almost a 10-point move it's like
nine points
and then you have
one two three bars right three bars with
zones being drawn out now when i say
earlier right you got earlier you had
two greens in a row one two
one
two now right one bar the immediate next
bar it's not one bar
and then nothing in the second bar and
then the third bar
when i see two in a row
one right after the other it's a trade
that
i i know which way the direction is
going right i don't need to wait for a
third one to come in here
be looking to get short for me i know i
can get short here and
you know my stop is just above the first
one right and you know the if you start
trading in there but i'm still loving it
you know i know i got another resistance
here because now i know i got overhead
resistance
right above me
and right above that all right so i know
that i've got some
you know there was selling in here
earlier that if the market came back up
in here that selling is probably still
going to be there
then you put in the third one here you
know so we're gap in the value here a
gap in the value
and i've talked about this
a long time ago right when you're seeing
one gap two gaps it's usually
gap and go right
gap
trading strategy you know two gaps in a
row is good enough to get short already
now we're adding another feature to make
it a bit clearer as you're seeing this
zone drawn out okay well you know i got
one gap here already
i've already got another zone being
drawn out
you know i know i can just hide behind
here right because i've got this whole
area up in here
so
you know you can wait until it gets down
in here
all right till this bar closes
but
if you're a little bit more aggressive
you think you just get in right away you
know in this bar because i know i'm
already forming two
okay so there's a chance that i'm
already below because again this is a
one minute
bar so you know chances are halfway
through the
minute it's already trading down here
but i've already got strong signs up in
here unless a piece
dropping right now um
because i want to take advantage this is
the bar that you want right these are
those bars that
you know you get in
and your
take profit is hit
you know within 10 seconds right those
are the type of parts you wish oh i wish
i moved my take profit but you know
those are the bars that you get
in and filled in the same bar that's
you know filled with your take profit
not your stop those are the good trades
to have okay so anyway the market came
back where to come back to came back to
this level right here
i it got through it by
two ticks right here
95 and three quarters 96
and then it had nice move down again
right this whole time right there's it's
all positive delta right you're thinking
okay maybe you know this market can
rally here you got a nice trade setup
this is the trade setup that i like i
like the bullish eva
with the slingshot point of control in
it
did it go higher yeah it went higher
two points but i know i got resistance
here now now i know i have this area
it's clear to me that yeah there's this
area right here
that
is going to act as resistance so even if
i'm getting long in here
you know i sort of got to grip my teeth
and you know okay i get through this
area i got to get through this area i
get through this area
right i know i got
areas that the market could struggle to
get through at least for now right so
the market
did what it did right it came right back
up into those areas and then sold off
again
sold off nicely
okay now here you've got these two red
bars
with the zone drawn out but again what
is it it's a red candle red candle
but we're trading above it above the
zone train above the zone so it's it's
invalidated already right bar closes up
bar closed up
those zones are invalidated
okay so it's not i'm not looking
for these zones to be
support because they should be
resistance but you're trained above
resistance at that point
then
finally you get another one right down
here now this is not a
bearish eva
if this bar had this
lower value area than the previous bar
it's right at the same level so it's not
given that signal okay but it's still a
slingshot point control in there which
is bearish
i have a zone being drawn out already
again which is good
and i'm still trading below it a little
bit
four points below
rally back up to where right back into
that zone
okay and the market sold off again from
whoops
and again it's not like you have to you
know you put an offer in here you know
you can manage the trade with a stop
just on the other side of the zone
if it trades through it
okay i mean you know we wish every zone
would hold but sometimes this is what
they do right because where did it what
happened
sold off
into the previous zone here with that
was support rallied back up into that
zone and then sold off right now i'm not
saying you sold it right here and
covered it you know sold it at what is
that 75.76
and then covered down here in 63 64 at
the low you know i mean you would have
sold it up here you know 76 probably
covered somewhere down around seven you
know ideally 70. because again you're
going to look for the market to at least
come back down into 71 and a half
so from you know 76 down to 70
71.
five points
okay then the market started working its
way up
you get up here right you got a nice
zone being drawn out here you test it
come within one tick rally back up
okay you got another zone but again it
hadn't come in here yet another zone
formed here again you try to buy it in
here with the stop just on the other
side you get stopped out you come down
here again this trade fails this one
fails here too
so you got one two three losers i showed
you some really nice trades but
sometimes
it just overshoots it
okay
and so i have this one forming right in
here
right next bar again we get within one
tick of it then the next bar trades in
and just sort of hangs around
you know doesn't move much lower
unfortunately even though it tests that
area it's a big zone in here
and then we're sort of coming up later
in the day
now i have these zones here from way
earlier way way that was those were
those two from you know when we had the
two in a row
right here
came off
at this point you know the volatility is
picking up how can you tell the
volatility is picking up well
you look at some of these bars i mean
obviously this big
bar here i mean you're talking a range
of um 71 and a quarter so call it 71 up
to 91 so a 20 point range in one bar now
when you start seeing bars like that you
know
something's amiss you know and
it was you know biden
it was two o'clock compressor that would
change to one o'clock then did it at two
o'clock because there's an hour delay or
something like that it's
you know
yeah it's kind of
[Music]
bizarre the way this
political scene is now but you know the
volatility is picked up and if
volatility is starting to pick up
be careful
trying to trade zones zones work great
in
normal market conditions but
when know sort of the the monopoly board
is thrown off the table you know
things can get wild that's why it's not
uncommon to start seeing when you start
seeing the levels getting blown through
right i know things are picking up
already here you know even in this bar
is about a 10 point bar 81 up to
what is that 92 right it's over 10
points there
and then i've got this other bar here
already
right 94
down to 81.
so you know another 13 point bar and it
just blew right through that level now
i've got two one two okay gap gap
gap here we're trading way up here
now
um
i know volatility is picked up right i
know i got gap
here i know i've got new zones two new
zones here okay and we just
came and blew right through this level
here right this is a nice bearish bar
it's a bearish slingshot point of
control that red point of control
and the zone is red the value area is
red okay so i know that's a bearish bar
it did sell off
okay
and then it just turned on a dime and
rallied straight through that in one bar
didn't just oftentimes you're going to
see the little rally come back up in
here sort of go sideways it just blew
right through it and blew through it
more importantly
look at the volume there's very light in
there
you know one against 51 3 against 41 you
know 11 against 17 31 against 17 5
against 14 12 against 20. so i know the
market's moving faster when i see
volume like this
again you know s ps
you should see several hundreds being
traded and you're seeing a lot of these
bars
with
volumes
in the teens so there's not necessarily
a lot even though the total volume for
the bar is decent three thousand three
thousand four thousand
you know six thousand it's taking the
market
more
price levels
to transact
trade basically because it's looking for
liquidity is what's happening right
people are just buying whatever's there
in this case now they're buying
whatever's there that's why you have
bars that are 15 20 points
so at this point i'm not looking for
these areas to be holding anymore i know
i just blew through this level easily on
very light
volume cutting through that level
right because normally you should see
regular normal size bars i hate to say
normal size bars in this and p b and 10
points but you know
something manageable with volume but
you're not seeing much volume go through
you know when your imbalance is only 41
contracts you know there's not a lot
trading on the other side and in the s
ps to have a
imbalance you know four against twenty
seven one against ten
that's not normal right you don't
normally see that that
lack of liquidity in the s ps unless
something is happening
so i'm not looking for these levels
necessarily to be holding already
because i've already got something very
bullish going on in these two bars
okay so then the market just blew right
through it and obviously continued
higher so
if you take away one thing today
look for these bars where you have the
two consecutive in this case if you're
using the value areas
um where they're being
zones drawn out right you don't need to
necessarily wait
too long right especially if you see the
gap like that it's pretty clear right
and the second bar doesn't even come in
anywhere near right it's way above it's
almost
you know one of the things i wanted to
talk about probably in in the future is
i want to talk about these
valuary highs in one bar versus value
area lows in another bar um and
when
you know just really briefly you know if
you want
you know if you're bored one night
i can't sleep
take a look at it
when you have
evaluate okay so if you have a green two
green bars
and the value area high of bar one
is not tested by the low of the previous
bar
that's usually a good sign
to
get going with that trade
just as
the opposite would be true if it was two
red bars at least
see if i find one in here um
[Music]
well it's probably right here
with these two here all right if the
value area low of this red candle here
is what 80 sorry 4301 and a half
the high of this bar is o1 so you have a
gap between the high
of the second bar and the value area low
of the previous bar just like you have
here right
it's just right on the edge 99 and a
quarter
value area low here's 99
also in quarters the high so let's just
write the same level
but
when the high of the second bar
if it's two red candles doesn't get into
the
value area low
all right that's usually
a good trade to take gives you you know
it's a directional clue right you're
always looking for these
directional clues in the market anyway
um i sort of digress
all right so let's go back here
okay so yeah the market just
steamrolled the head up and up and up
now things are calming down right s ps
are sort of back in there i was saying
again i don't say normal but you know
you're talking to range you know 03 up
to what is that night at 10 so 7 points
um again the bars are a bit normalized
now you know 10 and a quarter
you know 16 and a half
and now you're starting to see what time
is it three two o'clock um this zone you
know this zone didn't hold went up came
down we got a new area in here and just
sort of what i talked about earlier
right you have the value area high of
this bar
this green bar with the zone being drawn
out as 15.
the low of the next bar also a green
candle so green green
the low is you know 15 and a quarter so
there's a gap between the value area
high here and the low of this bar right
here
and then they kept going higher
we went all the way up to what is that
so
you know
this bar closed at what is that 18 and a
quarter this bar opened up 18 and a half
trade all the way up to what is that 20
up to 30. there's that big size up there
at 30.
um
over 2500 it came so tested there right
bearish prominent point of control right
it's right on the extreme
obviously it's a
bearish ratio telling you the stopping
volume there
and yeah the mark came off a little bit
um like i say a little bit but it's it's
a move from all the way down to what is
that 18
from 30.
and then it's going to come back up and
test it once twice finally the third
time we get through it all right you
know and again you know people they see
that size it's mesmerizing right you see
big size in the market
you know all you know how many thousands
are there sometimes people sit there and
they wonder um
you know really is is it two and a half
thousand three thousand five thousand
so it turned out to be about
three and a half thousand
and it came back up and finally got
through it but what did it do it got
through it by
two points
okay but along the way
okay so we have this zone being drawn
out here this zone
drawn out here came back in tested it
rallied back up again even though you
have this green zone right we're trading
below it right so it's
i'm looking for green zones to be
support not resistance
right so we trade back into this zone
you know 22 and a half
rally all the way back up to 30 where we
have that level finally get through it
leaves off this zone up in here
right this was an area up in here of 30.
uh 4250 last night
after the reopen um you know the low
was interesting i'll talk about that in
a second um
[Music]
then the market started coming off
again came down tested this low now it's
2 30 right where cash closes at three
um blew through this area
rallied back up got what got right one
tick into this zone
and then started trading back down you
know i blew through this level here
all right if you're looking for that
resistance it just just wasn't there
but it tested the next one the next one
held
and then it sold off again you know
again from that
28 area all the way down into the the
teens
leaving another zone right here came
back in rallied back up into that zone
right 21 and a quarter held it
same bar
right
from 21 and a quarter literally down to
you know 12.
what is that 11 and a half
so you know
it is a nice a nice move from you know
right back down to
down to uh you know 12 basically in that
one bar
um now we're coming up on the cash close
here
and no more
zones you have that zone from way
earlier down here 4290 is a big zone
now
you know one of the tests that we've
been
doing research on is
is the bigger the zone
the the stronger the zone and
it's
so far it's inconclusive
because we're trying to figure out what
exactly considers a big zone because you
know some markets
you know like in the s ps right this
zone is being drawn out is
you know what is that 91 and a half down
to
83 and a half okay well that's a lot of
risk involved you know if you're buying
it somewhere in here 91 and a quarter
even the top you know 91 and a half and
you're risking almost 10 points
um
you know because your stop would be on
the other side you know 82 and a half so
that's nine points i don't know if a lot
of people really want to do that
but
some of our tests have shown that sort
of the bigger the areas
they tend to hold
a bit better but at the same time since
it's a bigger
since it's a bigger area
you have more space okay so it's
it's one of these things that yeah i got
ten point i got nine points of wiggle
room
right and nine points a wiggle room is a
lot
as opposed to
um
you know a tighter zone right in here
you're talking
73 i was at 70 and 3 4 or 21
to 24 three points right it's a third
the size
okay so you know your
your stop is
much
neater right it's only
three and a half points whereas here
basically your stop is almost 10 points
right and it's one of those things where
you know i see people they have zones
sometimes drawn
in nasdaq that are 50 points
zone and
it's like oh yeah my level held well
your level's 50 points
you know
it should hold
um you know you could go down
you know you're buying it at
at
90 and it trades all the way down to
50.
you know that that's a lot of risk to be
taken but
um
whatever